Cold, distant and mysterious.
For decades after its discovery in 1930, little was known about the geology of Pluto.
NASA's New Horizons probe was the first spacecraft to explore Pluto up close...
...and it sent back some fascinating images.
The patterns can be seen across the smooth surface of a basin filled with nitrogen ice.
Now, a team of researchers has a new explanation for Pluto's mysterious polygons.
Looking at New Horizons' high-resolution images of Pluto,...
...several researchers were intrigued by markings in the region known as Sputnik Planitia,...
...where dark lines formed geometric shapes several tens of kilometers wide.
Even though Sputnik Planitia is made of solid ice,...
...slow-moving currents are still the most likely explanation.
The convection currents that make these kinds of patterns...
...are usually driven by heating from below,...
...but there was something about the patterns on Pluto's surface...
...that didn't quite fit with the idea of convection currents...
...being driven by Pluto's internal heat.
The visible lines delineating the polygons are troughs,...
...showing that the convection currents must be rising up in the center of each shape...
...and sinking at the edges,...
...the opposite to what you'd get if you were heating from underneath.
To explain this cooling, Stephane and his team turned to sublimation.
This is the process, similar to evaporation,...
...by which the nitrogen ice of Sputnik Planitia turns from a solid straight into a gas.
To test this theory, the team developed a computer simulation of the surface.
Their model shows, for the first time, that sublimation can drive planetary-scale patterns.
The team are confident in their findings,...
...but it might be a while before all their hypotheses can be fully tested.